what I'm saying is we can't just keep
going the way we're going we're not
going to get anywhere so I'm suggesting
that we go in a different direction and
that's my plan but you're not going to
get anywhere with your plan either
because the UK government will say no
and where does that leave your plans
there will of the Scottish people will
not be denied so if the UK government
says no what happens then
this is going to be a clear instruction
from the people of Scotland about what
they want to do yeah but if the UK
government says no what happens then I
don't think the UK government will say
that if they do then we will adapt and
what does adapting look like I'm not
going to set that out at this point